cheese butter is the delicious gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter i love this
stuff perfect on bread bagels sandwiches
veggies and more and you'll get 20 off
when you go to cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below this
morning we woke up to what was reported
as a shocking number 33 percent 33
percent approval for president joe biden
a disastrously low number and the number
is true
but we're going to contextualize it it's
just one poll and while overall joe
biden's approval is not
great
it's still better than trump's was at
this point in time in trump's presidency
so without context the 33 number is not
worth that much
but it is not a good number so let's
start with that 33 number we have a new
quinnipiac poll and indeed the poll
finds
and quinnipiac is a good good pollster
that only 33 percent of americans
approve
of the way that joe biden is handling
his job this is a tie
for the low
ever received by biden in this poll
with january 12th
when it was also
33
now the main question for me
is
why is it low
and what could raise it really the key
to questions with any presidential
approval poll but then we're also going
to compare it to other approval polls so
looking at the quinnipiac poll
we find that
only 39 of americans
approve of joe biden's handling of the
response to the russian invasion of
ukraine 39
that's a much lower number than we saw
weeks ago
in other polls now part of it could be
the way the poll is done and part of it
likely is a decline in approval of how
joe biden has handled that situation um
interestingly more than eight in ten
americans believe russian president
vladimir putin is a war criminal
something that donald trump uh hesitates
to say and uh we we will get to that a
little bit later 10 believe putin is not
a war criminal
seven in ten think putin ordered russian
troops to kill civilians in ukraine
fourteen percent think that he did not
so this is the quinnipiac poll
well what about more generally speaking
what's going on with joe biden's
approval well for that one of the best
places to look is the 538 biden approval
which looks at an average of recent
approval polls and when we look there
we find that it's not as bad for joe
biden
certainly it's not good and as you can
see early in his presidency joe biden in
the mid 50s in terms of approval then
moving into the low 50s crossing below
the 50 percent line getting down into
the mid 40s and then into the low 40s
and most recently we see this little
decline from about 42 to 41. if you look
more deeply at the specific polls making
that up and this is where we would say
okay what is where does the quinnipiac
poll fit into this uh we see that
um the quinnip this recent quinnipiac
university poll is here which has joe
biden at 33
that is an outlier in the sense that all
of the other recent polls have joe biden
between 38 and 44. does that mean the
quinnipiac poll is wrong well no it
doesn't mean it's wrong but it does mean
it is sort of an outlier and when 538
applies what they call an adjustment
the 33 becomes 37. so needless to say
this is not a good situation
uh for joe biden and the question now is
going to be well what needs to happen
for that to change because these are not
great numbers the next question would be
are these guaranteed to be destructive
numbers looking forward at the midterms
and potentially at 2024. well one thing
we can look at there
is how does
the current biden approval
41. something
how does that compare with other
presidents at this point in their
presidencies if you look at biden versus
trump you find that at this point in
time
trump actually was at 40.6 i mean it's
more or less the same but biden's
approval today
is slightly better than was trump's at
this point in his presidency if you
compare biden to basically any other
recent president you see that barack
obama had a higher approval at this
point in time
george w bush had a dramatically higher
approval uh thanks to 9 11. bill clinton
had a higher approval than biden george
h.w bush had a much higher approval than
biden reagan had a higher approval than
biden you have to go all the way back to
jimmy carter to even get close uh and
even then
just at this time carter also did better
uh than biden but soon uh jimmy carter
started seeing a reduction what does
this mean for 2022 it's not good it's
not good there's really no way to spin
it that feels
empirically honest and i know that
you're going to see hot takes from uh
democratic uh pollsters and operatives
and analysts that are saying well listen
the midterms are not necessarily a
referendum on biden and xyz but if this
doesn't change it's going to be a
disaster for democrats
there's just no way around it um it is
going to be potentially one of the worst
midterms for democrats in a very long
time now what could change it many
things could change it if the american
perception of the economy
improves between now and november it's
good for democrats and i know many of
you will say but david the numbers are
good for the economy you're absolutely
right but we did a story early last week
about the difference between an economic
reality and a political reality
jobs numbers are dramatically better now
than when joe biden took over but a
third of the country doesn't think so a
third of the country thinks jobs have
been lost i know we can say oh those
stupid ig
if that's what they believe they're
going to vote on that basis and so what
matters is what people what people
believe uh some kind of satisfactory
resolution in ukraine and it's hard to
use that language given the death and
destruction that's been seen there some
kind of politically satisfactory
resolution will likely be helpful to
democrats because i believe that the
midterms are a referendum on joe biden i
think there's no way to argue that that
they are not but not good numbers for
joe biden and if nothing changes that's
the key if nothing changes it will be a
disastrous midterm for democrats if you
disagree with me let me know tell me how
the current numbers translate to an okay
midterm for democrats i just don't see
it
i want to look at a very disturbing
video not disturbing in the sense that
it's gory not disturbing in the sense
that there's bad words swears as we
might say
it's disturbing because it is
another one of these examples of how
conspiracy theories rarely live alone in
someone's brain and we talked about this
with dr stephen novella earlier in the
week and we've talked about this with
other experts on conspiratorial thinking
they say well
flat earth it's so benign okay you think
the earth is flat but that's it doesn't
mean well no typically these conspiracy
conspiratorial beliefs come in groups
and an attendee at a chuck grassley town
hall
said
putin's not bad because he's fighting
nazis and what about the ukrainian
biolabs and the pedophilia and there's
deep state corruption in ukraine
and it's emblematic of how it's never
just one conspiracy theory and maybe
just as disturbing
is that chuck grassley doesn't seem to
push back against any of these
take a look at this this is what america
has become
half of america and on what you know
about
uh bio labs
uh
the financing that uh putin has stopped
over in ukraine the neo-nazis the nazis
and the
pedophilia that goes on in ukraine by
the way
pedophilia i i just love that
not only are they often confused by the
conspiracies it's a word salad a pet or
feel it come on guys okay and who's
there stopping it but our news doesn't
bring that out do you know anything
about that
well you mentioned four things so
on a pedophile that's i don't know
whether there's anything special about
ukraine and pedophile i but i do know
that human trafficking and not just sex
trafficking but human trafficking for
economic slavery
is an internet it's bad in the united
states but it's worse internationally
and so i suppose that there's some of
that in ukraine but i can't say that
it's worse there than other places and
then what did you bring up the bio labs
um
the financing that's he stopped over
there and then the nazi neo-nazis in
ukraine well the financing uh
hasn't stopped because congress
appropriated 14 billion dollars
uh seven for humanitarian
for military so
so you uh maybe you just saw on
television that no i don't watch
something okay
no he's getting his news exclusively
from facebook he doesn't watch
that the tv the reply of the bio
or do not buy the biolabs but i mean the
deep state funding already oh it's now
deep state i see
[Music]
the lab
something that was set up in the so you
know chuck grassley is kind of taking
this piece by piece but the really the
problem here is
sir
you've fallen for a package
of of claims
individually each of which is not what
you've been told is there is there
trafficking in ukraine yes there's a
there's a problem with trafficking in
eastern europe but the problem is in
russia as well
and putin's invasion of ukraine is no
more justified because ukraine also has
trafficking
the bio labs thing the bio labs in
ukraine are not unique
they're not particularly pernicious
there's nothing special about them the
us is part of a consortium that funds
research all over the world there's many
labs in europe some of them are in
ukraine deep state well what what are
you talking about
it's almost like there's a um
it's like a starter pack of conspiracy
beliefs where it's like a word salad it
just comes out of them almost like
they've taken some kind of
conspiratorical conspiratorial ayahuasca
and everything is just being come it's
just you can't stop it they're they're
just vomiting it out into a bucket the
way many on ayahuasca do um this is an
example of it's never just one
conspiracy theory and this is what we've
been talking about for a long time um i
i would have loved to have seen
from chuck grassley remember this moment
when during the 2008 presidential
campaign a woman said to john mccain the
late senator john mccain who was the
presidential candidate obama's a muslim
and he's an arab and mccain said no he's
not now i would have loved to have seen
in this clip
it's also okay to be muslim in this
country
but
okay chuck grassley not exactly living
up to this standard i can't trust obama
i i have read about him and he's not
he's not he's a
um
he's an arab
he is not
no man no man he's a he's a he's a
decent family man citizen that i just
happen to have disagreements with on on
fundamental issues right and also
if he wasn't an arab
uh or muslim as people would say at the
time sometimes
you're allowed to be muslim and
president in the united states i mean we
haven't had one okay but you're you're
you actually are allowed to do it so
chuck grassley not not even living up to
that standard but this stuff is
dangerous
and the republican party by and large at
least welcomes it by looking the other
way let me know your thoughts you can
find me on twitter at dpakman
one of our sponsors is cheese butter
giving you 20
off cheese butter is a delicious gourmet
cheese melt that ingeniously blends for
indulgent cheeses and artisanal seasoned
butter i love this stuff cheese bud is
the type of thing you've got to try to
really understand there's so many
different things i was already putting
cheese and butter on but by combining
top shelf cheeses and butters together
cheese butter unlocks a new level of
tasty gourmet goodness and there are
actually several cuisines with sauces
that mix these ingredients it may be new
to you but it is a
tried and true combination
very often cheese butter will make an
appearance when i'm cooking at home i
put it on french and sourdough bread
bagels english muffins it's great on
sandwiches grilled cheese burgers baked
potatoes mac and cheese broccoli
broccolini my beloved broccolini other
vegetables i'm sure there's lots of
other home chefs in the audience who can
come up with some great ways to use
cheese butter and you'll now get 20 off
when you go to cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below
the david pakman show continues to
depend on you to fund what we do we have
a membership program at
joinpacman.com and i would love for you
to sign up we do an extra show every day
for our members and you can use the code
wow 22
to save a surprising amount off of the
cost of a membership
we have yet another example now of
failed former president donald trump
being given the opportunity to just
cleanly condemn the russian president
vladimir putin and his invasion of
ukraine and he doesn't do it last night
the former failed president was
interviewed by fox news propagandist
sean hannity and in a moment we're going
to get to some of this windmill stuff
trump's still very confused about
windmills and we're going to do a little
bit of a deeper dive into
windmills and birds
but before we get to that here's the
opportunity hannity just says it is this
evil just tease up an easy one for trump
to condemn putin
and trump doesn't delivering another one
of these word salads take a listen to
this asked you the last time you were on
whether you think that this is evil in
our time do you believe this is evil in
our time right
i think in 100 years people are going to
look back
and they're going to say how did we
stand back and nato
stand backwards so that's a criticism
of nato and of biden understand hannity
says it is this evil is putin evil is
what russia's doing evil and he goes
the history books are not going to look
kindly at nato and the united states and
biden now also remember well let's play
a little more in many ways i've called a
paper tiger don't forget
i rebuilt nato because when i became
president the first thing i noticed when
i went there to the first meeting was
that
most of the countries were not paying or
were paying far less than they were
supposed to there were only eight out of
28 countries that were paid in full the
united states was not only one of them
we were making up the deficits in order
to protect europe we were paying
possibly 80 of nato to protect them and
then they take advantage of us yet on
trade because on trade they're every bit
as bad as china they treated us very
badly on trade we changed a lot of that
around but they were very tough on trade
i asked angela merkel how many
chevrolets guys remember the question
was is it evil what putin is doing and
trump's criticizing nato
implicitly criticizing biden for not
doing enough and now criticizing angela
merkel are you selling this month in
munich
or berlin
and she looked at me well probably none
i said you're exactly right none and yet
we had the mercedes-benz and the
volkswagens and all of them we had all
of the german companies and the same
thing with farmers our farmers sell
virtually nothing
to europe you take a look at
how crazy is that i mean really how
bonkers is that is is is putin's
invasion evil
why aren't americans uh american cars
being sold in germany that's really bad
and nato's bad and biden's bad and and
by the way we've trump seems obsessed
with why you don't see people driving
around in chevies in germany guys i i i
hate to be critical of american industry
but like if you can get a volkswagen
locally produced if you can get a
mercedes or an audi locally produced
why are you gonna say
get me an american chevy i mean
germany has very good cars like it's
it's anyway so another opportunity to
just plainly cleanly criticize putin's
invasion and trump doesn't do it now
there was another really wacky moment in
this interview which is not getting as
much attention listen to what donald
trump had to say
about uh bald eagles
as he says
being killed by windmills trump is very
much against wind farms he says the
noise causes cancer not true uh and
listen to what he had to say
windmills because they're killing eagles
they're killing the bald eagle and other
eagles and other birds and we have these
windmills all over the place and the
environmentalists pretend they love them
but they're really hurting our country
they're driving down values they're just
absolutely killing it's one of the most
expensive forms of energy the turbines
are all made in china or germany so they
get the advantage of that
uh it's just ridiculous but the real
problem yeah
um do so so this has been studied and
this trump has been repeating this for
years and many on the right have been
repeating this about wind farms
do windmills kill some birds yes they do
they do windmills kill
from
about two hundred and thirty thousand to
three hundred and thirty thousand birds
per year wow okay well that that's
significant right well maybe
cell and radio towers
cause nearly seven million bird deaths
per year well wait a wait a second the
wind farms kill 250 000 call it and the
cell and radio towers kill 7 million yes
and they never talk about that
cats okay i know a lot of cat owners
don't like this
cats kill
1.4 to 3.7
billion birds a year
billion with a b
okay so windmills are having no
statistically significant effect on the
bird population but you know what maybe
i'm being unfair because i'm comparing
bird deaths
from an energy generation mechanism to
other types of bird deaths okay well
if you consider
the oil and gas fields oil and gas
fields
kill
500 000 to a million birds per year
already and you never hear about it okay
so this is a completely hypocritical
talking point everything we do has an
effect do you wear a cotton
cotton requires a lot of water the water
that goes to make cotton clothing leads
to frogs and salamanders
dying because they have no environment
anymore the water is gone
okay i mean so then we'll maybe switch
to synthetic clothing oh but that's that
those are oil derivatives in many cases
and then you've got the birds
these things are complicated but one
thing we know for sure is that the bird
death toll from windmills is
statistically insignificant compared to
all the other things that we have in
industry that are killing birds now in
terms of eagles there's really no
specific data on how many bald eagles
are being killed by wind turbines the
estimate is that in total about a
hundred eagles a year die from wind
turbines in theory some of the hundred
are bald eagles i don't know it depends
you'd have to look more we don't have
that data but way more eagles die from
other things humans do
if you care about the eagles do you know
how many eagles die from hitting cars
do you know how many eagles die from
eating leftover lead uh i don't know if
it's called buckshot or just shot you
know ordinance of sort ammunition spend
it used eagles eat it and then they die
or eagles hitting electrified power
lines well shouldn't we be bearing power
lines oh no that's too expensive we
can't do that so this is nonsense it's
nonsense but as as is often the case
there's like a tiny somewhere there's
like a tiny little kernel of something
true about it and then they fixate on it
and then they blow it up and then they
repeat it uncritically so a very strange
interview there with sean hannity i
don't want to spend a ton of time on
this because i believe there's going to
be more time for it but one of the big
questions about 2024 is
is joe biden going to run for
re-election i think he's not that's my
opinion as of right now but i could be
wrong it's just a guess i i'm terrible
at making predictions i thought hillary
would win in 2016. so it's just my
opinion and it doesn't really matter i
just don't think joe biden's running for
re-election in 2024. the other side of
that is is trump running for re-election
in 2024
i have been leaning very heavily towards
yes for a while when i interviewed
michael cohen trump's former lawyer
michael cohen said i don't think trump's
going to run because he's going to
realize he can't win and his ego can't
handle another loss okay that's another
opinion but one of the things i've been
mentioning is
i am unsure what trump's health is going
to look like in 2024 but he's not a
healthy guy and he's not a particularly
young guy okay just it's just actuarial
realities fair
for the first time that i've ever seen
donald trump is now starting to talk
about his health as a possible reason
that he wouldn't run and the question is
regardless of the truth about his health
is he just starting to lay the
groundwork for using health as an excuse
not to run this is from an interesting
interview in the washington post with
josh dossey
this was from um
this is from a few days ago the article
is called trump deflects blame for
january 6 silence says he wanted to
march to the capitol
i don't want to talk about that part of
it i want to talk specifically about the
end of this article where trump actually
talks about the issue of 2024 and health
check this out let's put it up on the
screen
trump said it was true he had told
advisors that his health would factor
into whether he would run again in 2024
but that he was currently in good health
quote you always have to talk about
health you look like you're in good
health but tomorrow you get a letter
from a doctor saying come see me again
that's not good when they use the word
again so this is typical trump speak
where we're like left wondering is is he
saying this because he already knows
about a health issue or not or does he
just what what is this about it's it's
cryptic it's always completely cryptic
but this is the first time i'm aware of
that donald trump has floated what will
his health status be in 2024
as a factor now i've been saying it's a
factor obviously if he's not healthy
he's not going to be able to run but
trump is now laying it out there and
there's two perspectives one is there's
something going on with trump and this
is how he's starting to allude to it
the second perspective is
this is just setting up an excuse but
trump has no intention of running what
trump wants to do is to continue
dangling that he might run the way he's
been doing at rallies saying you're
going to be very happy in 2024 we're
going to take it back in 2024 suggesting
that he's going to run in order to keep
fundraising for his pack which is pretty
clearly being used as a slush fund to
hire family members and who knows what
else he has millions of reasons right
now to pretend that he's going to run in
2024 and he may not even really be
planning to do it we just don't know
what we do know is
health which i've been talking about for
over a year now
actually being mentioned by trump as far
as i know for the first time uh we'll
have more coverage of this interview on
our instagram at david pakman show and
you can let us know there in a comment
what do you think is the meaning of this
health issue being brought up by trump
for the first time let us know
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to have back on the show
today nick majuli who is the coo at
ritholtz wealth management also founder
of of dollars and data a data focused
personal finance blog and also author of
the new book just keep buying proven
ways to save money and build your wealth
uh nick the the book is killing on
amazon it's crazy what's going on
i appreciate it yeah it's been a crazy
few days so far
so you know one of the questions i often
get from my viewers is are financial
advisors a scam and what i try to
explain is at the individual level no
the answer is no i mean sure there are
financial advisors whose practices are
scammy and there's financial advisors
that that that are not but what i say
the scam is
is that the financial services industry
has sold the idea to people that basic
personal finance is really complicated
and you can't handle it yourself and
what you do in your book is you explain
in really clear terms the most important
you know eight to ten principles about
managing money and you really explain
that it's not as complicated as maybe
the industry wants you to believe is
that fair
yeah i think that's true at times i mean
obviously it depends on your situation i
think that when financial planning makes
the most sense is the more complex it
gets especially with taxes so usually i
think for most people it doesn't make
sense to be paying a fee if you don't
have a lot of nasa it's very simple i
mean unless you just want the peace of
mind and so that's what a lot of people
really that you know i work in the
wealth management industry full
disclosure of course a lot of people
come to us for us for the peace of mind
it's not necessarily like you know it's
not that they couldn't do it themselves
a lot of times there's like i don't want
to do it i'm going to spend my time
doing something more valuable and i
think that's why for a lot of people
it's worth
the price they pay one of the things
that um you talk about in the book and
you back it up with data is kind of the
futility of this idea of
when should i be
investing how when is the right time to
to sort of get in and to get out and
this is something i've talked to my
audience about a lot and every time that
the markets are shaky and we saw this in
march of 2020 at the start of the
pandemic we've seen it over the last two
months
so many people you look at twitter you
look at reddit you look at all these
different places they're saying i'm
gonna give it five more days or i'm
gonna wait or this isn't exactly the
right time statistic aside from anyone's
opinions about their ability to predict
the future which is not very good humans
are not particularly good at that
lay out the statistical case for why it
doesn't really make sense to be doing
that
yeah so if you're trying to wait so
waiting to like buy a dip is one thing
and then just waiting at all is usually
a bad idea and the reason why is because
most of the time markets you know
generally increase over time of course
there's gonna be cases where markets
crash and things like that but you know
if you're going to compare someone who's
trying to even if you know i'm using the
book chapter 14 it's called even god
couldn't beat dollar cost averaging and
i basically say i'm going to tell you
when the dips are and you're going to
save cash and buy those dips like the
lowest point between two all-time highs
like on a monthly basis and that
strategy actually underperforms someone
who's just buys every month like 80 of
the time and the reason why is because
by the time you wait for that big dip by
the time it happens that price that dip
price is higher than where you could
have bought originally right so you're
like you're always ending up buying at a
higher price and so there's always gonna
be reasons to sell like you can all you
always can you know psych yourself out
about this stuff and don't get me wrong
sometimes people are gonna move to cash
and they're gonna be right once in a
while right and they're gonna be right
in the short run but i think the
behavioral reason why you shouldn't do
it is you're going to be wrong in the
long run right if imagine every time you
know imagine and you know after 2009
you're like wow this i'm going to stay
out of the market for a while 2010 2011
you stay out you're like wow look i'm
smart or whatever markets are covered a
little bit but then you stay out for the
next five 10 years and you miss one of
the biggest bull markets in history
right and that's what's happened there's
been people saying the stock market's
been overvalued since 2012 2013 the
market's been on an upward tear since so
one day they'll be right but they're
going to be wrong most of the time and
that's the issue here the the other
concern i would have with such a
strategy and many of my friends do this
stuff and i tell them i think you're i
think you're wasting your time
is that i'm big on systematizing what
i'm trying to do with my finances and
even if you believe that you would be
really good at figuring out okay we've
hit the bottom now is the time to start
buying again
it's not a systematic approach and the
systematic approach has the advantages
number one of being in my mind far less
stressful and anxiety causing number two
if you continue your investment plan on
the way down
you're actually getting more value for
your money in the sense that a hundred
dollars buys you more shares when the
market is down than when the market is
up
and thirdly and correct me if i'm wrong
you're continuing to accumulate
dividends during that time and somebody
who is just waiting is is not going to
be doing that so it seems that the
systematic aspect has both psychological
and financial benefits
yeah i completely agree and so the whole
like my argument is like you know do
something better with your time right
like like david i think you're probably
better suited to be you know hosting a
youtube show and talking about this then
spending you know five ten hours a week
looking at your investments right if you
think about the return you're gonna get
on your personal human capital and for
someone else i may be like oh i'm a
photography person like maybe you should
do more photo shoots or someone you know
is a writer and so they should write
more blog posts whatever it is whatever
you do like i bet there's some higher
value activity you have than going and
investing and doing that stuff with your
money especially if you don't have a lot
of money invested if you have ten
thousand dollars invested right let's
say you can you know increase your
returns by you know let's say
10 right that's a thousand bucks unless
you spend 10 hours a week doing that
over the course of a year right so let's
say 10 times you know 50 500. you spend
500 hours to make a thousand dollars
like think about that like it's so silly
like you would no you should you should
literally just get this part-time job
you'd make way more money right so it's
one of those things when you start
thinking about the math on it you're
like wow my hourly wage of doing this
doesn't make any sense you know if you
have 10 million dollars that's a little
different but you know most of us don't
so
when it comes to uh debt there's there's
some interesting parts of the book about
you talk about mortgages uh you talk
about debt in different ways
debt is very polarizing and i don't mean
necessarily politically polarizing i'm
not talking about the national debt i'm
talking about personal debt people's
decisions about credit cards as well as
people's decisions about mortgages and
very commonly you'll you'll hear
strategies espoused i if i understand
correctly uh christian financial guy
dave ramsey talks about starting um with
i don't remember if it's the smallest
debt or the highest interest debt first
everybody has some algorithm that they
will sometimes apply
what's often missing from those
conversations are the sort of
psychological impacts of having the debt
and so when people sometimes have called
i guess they call me because my
background was in financial planning
although i haven't been in that space
for 15 years they'll say should one pay
off a mortgage if you have the cash to
do it and you can run the numbers
calculating what's your mortgage
interest deduction and what's the
interest rate you can do all that
but at the end of the day there's an
intangible which is like psychologically
what is having the debt do for your
day-to-day and that can be much harder
to kind of wrap wrap our minds around
can it not
yeah i think some of the the data on
that's interesting so the only debt that
didn't have any sort of psychological
impact at least on average across the
population was
mortgage debt that's the only every
other debt messes with people if you
have credit card debt that's usually
stressful if you have other type medical
debt whatever that usually affects
people's psyche they found that mortgage
debt generally doesn't affect people
however there is a subset of the
population that doesn't feel comfortable
with any debt and that's fine so you're
not going to want to hold debt at all so
even those people like i know people
very smart in the financial space and
they've paid off their homes despite the
fact that they had like a three percent
interest rate you know and they did that
because they just want the peace of mind
and so for some people peace of mind is
going to be better than all that other
stuff and so just you have to think
about that you know when you're making
these types of financial decisions so
there's nothing wrong with it but just
you kind of have to know yourself right
there's almost a as a
a story as old as time this is like a
philosophical point that's been around
for thousands of years like know thyself
right like so once you know kind of what
you like and don't like that's how you
can make better decisions with your
money when it comes to timing and real
estate
uh
are the principles different than when
it comes to timing the stock market in
the sense of if you have a need for
housing you can choose to buy or you can
choose to rent and very often rents will
reflect
the cost to whoever ultimately owns the
property in which you're going to live
so there's there's a correlation there
although it may not be perfect all of
the time
um sometimes people who already own a
place say well i'd like to move but i
want to wait
until the property is worth more but
then in in all likelihood the property
you're looking to buy will also have
increased in value unless you've got
maybe some market arbitrage because
you're looking to move or something like
that how does the timing piece affect
the purchase of property
so yeah i think because like every so if
you're saying like oh i'm going to buy
like a reit right you're going to put
money into like a reit fund that has
you're owning a broad basket of you know
commercial properties or whatever
commercial and residential properties
across the u.s i think timing's not
going to matter that much i mean
obviously there will be ebbs and flows
in the market overall however when
you're buying an individual property
timing matters a lot because you can
the corollary in the stock market is
like going from buying the s p 500 index
fund to just buying apple you're buying
a single buying one individual property
is like buying a single stock right so
you have single stock risk in your
individual home so like of course
timing's gonna matter in the sense that
there's a lot more risk when you buy an
individual stock or an individual
property so like
there's no real great way around that
right you're you're gonna have to take
that individual stock risk so to speak
with that individual property and so
like yes timing's gonna matter and
you're right that like other properties
will go up in value too so you just
gotta figure out like hey is this the
right time for me and don't try to look
at it as an investment i think when you
buy a home it needs to be something more
for your personal life societal reasons
where you're doing it maybe your
personal life stable now you have a few
kids or whatever and you know like hey
this is the neighborhood i want to be in
this is everything i want and you just
move and i think if you think about it
as an investment it's going to be really
tough for you because your home should
not be i mean it can be an investment
but you can't eat the equity your home
price could double you can't do anything
about that especially if you move to
another home you end up selling at home
buying another one what what did you
actually earn nothing right if all the
prices move so you can't eat your equity
unfortunately until you do some sort of
arbitrage like you said like the
californians moving to idaho and et
cetera right so
so we've talked about stocks we've
talked about real estate uh
cryptocurrency cryptocurrency um there
are so many opinions many of them
informed many of them not informed many
of them misinformed on cryptocurrency
my view on cryptocurrency has been i
want some upside exposure there and so
years and years ago as we've talked
about before i got some bitcoin and some
ethereum
um and i kind of determined given its
volatility what's the right asset
allocation for me and for me it's about
three percent of my total assets and so
if it goes to zero i lose three percent
of my total assets at this point
it has grown so much and i've sold
pieces of it that even if it went to
zero i come out ahead but the point is
i'm thinking of the volatility
in determining what is my right exposure
in terms of asset allocation is this the
right approach when you are dealing with
a relatively new and volatile asset
yes i completely agree with that i
actually did a i did some analysis and i
found like the optimal portfolio had
like two percent bitcoin and that's
basically what my crypto allocation has
been so three two percent some go up to
five you know i think that's very
prudent i don't think there's much to
add i think you almost had a perfect
answer there so well let me let's so
let's then go in this direction there
seems to be
a sort of moral assessment done with
crypto that isn't always done with stock
holdings which i find interesting like
for example
when i hold a total stock market index
fund there are absolutely companies in
there that are probably not great
companies there's statistically speaking
there's companies in there that are
uh committing fraud of securities fraud
of some kind there's the full kind of
gamut
but i don't find myself emotionally tied
to that in the way that sometimes people
make very emotional reactions to bitcoin
or ethereum what do you think it is that
causes some at least to view these
things so differently
i think there's just so much fanaticism
on both sides so i think like the pro
crypto people are so pro crypto they can
only see that way and most of them i
think have like a very very large
percentage of their assets encrypted
it's gone up a lot
so they are going to be guys and there's
people on the other side who weren't in
on it and they think it's a big scam and
it's worthless and all the stuff and
they're going to be biased in their own
ways and i think it's really tough to
have a balanced view on this because
you're going to bring some bias in i'm
saying i have so i own some crypto i
think i'm trying to do in a prudent way
but you know i'm not perfect on it but
i'm probably slightly biased against it
only because it's not income producing
and so i kind of talk about that in the
book like income producing assets should
be the bulk of your wealth which is like
stocks bonds real estate things that
actually you know actually produce
income now bonds obviously have done
terribly recently but for most of
history they've been decent so you know
there's there's a lot of talk about
reducing bond allocation so and then
that makes sense
last thing i want to talk about in terms
of all the signals that people can pay
attention to if you have a systematic
plan an asset allocation and you just do
that every month it seems to me that
there would be very little financial
news that you would really need to pay
attention to in terms of like what's
actionable so let me just throw a few
things out there and you tell me whether
these things even really matter to the
average investor more and more articles
now talk about
when the yield curve inverts it signals
a coming recession that's like one that
that is out there and it's very popular
or when the cape ratio goes above or
below a certain place it signals that
okay so all these different things
aside from whether these are accurate
does it really matter to the average
investor if you have a systematic plan
because it's i'm not seeing how you
would change your behavior even if some
of these metrics were accurate
predictors
well so they actually yield current
version is a pretty decent predictor of
recession and so if you actually look at
the data after an inversion like yes
stock returns are lower the problem is
where like what are your options you're
like oh just move to bonds well guess
what bonds underperform stocks even
after yield curve inversion so like you
don't really have a choice you just kind
of have to like deal with a terrible
situation and that's probably what at
some point you know assuming history
repeats itself it doesn't always like
the august 29 inversion didn't lead to
recession i mean people say oh there was
a recession coveted you know 2020 but
i'm going to argue that the the current
version 2019 was not predicting the
covid you know let's be honest here i
would agree with this then so yeah so
you see my point my point is though
these things happen and they are
predictive of lower returns even like
higher cape is predicting lower returns
future returns i agree with that the
problem is what are your options what
are you going to do you can try and move
to cash in time but
the cape's been at 30 since 2017 the
market's doubled since then like what
you're going to be sitting there sitting
in cash while the market's doubled and
you're just now right now you're getting
eight percent inflation you're done so
like you kind of have to just go on this
wild ride and there's no real options
you have you know
uh the book is just keep buying proven
ways to save money and build your wealth
the book is listed at davidpakman.com
finance when you can see my other
finance books recommendations we've been
speaking with the book's author nick
majuli nick always great speaking with
you thanks
thanks david appreciate it
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show one of the things we've learned to
pay special attention to over the last
few years is when the american
republican party says
this is what the left is going to do
we should look really carefully at
whether what they mean is we're actually
already doing this and when it comes to
voter fraud we've increasingly learned
that all of the fear-mongering and all
of the allegations about what democrats
and the left are going to do
was actually stuff that almost
exclusively it was republicans doing
people voting twice
people voting in the names of dead
people all of these different things
we see
endless instances
on the right and donald trump's former
chief of staff mark meadows is now
really caught in the crosshairs i
recently told you guys that meadows is
under investigation for was he
registered to vote where he actually
lived there's some really fishy stuff
going on and the latest news is that
mark meadows has indeed now been removed
from the north carolina voter rolls in
the middle of this investigation axios
reporting former white house chief of
staff mark meadows was removed from
north carolina's voter roll monday
why it matters the move comes amid an
investigation into meadows for alleged
voter fraud related to his voter
registration the probe followed reports
which revealed that meadows registered
to vote in north carolina in september
2020 using an address he allegedly never
visited
state of play meadows was removed from
the north carolina voter roll after
documentation indicated uh-oh he lived
in virginia and last voted in the 2021
election there
no formal challenge has been received by
the macon county board of elections
the last election he voted in macon
county was 2020.
under state law if a north carolina
voter exercises the right of a citizen
by voting in an election in another
state the person is considered to have
lost their north carolina residents now
there's two issues here remember
republicans kept talking about people
registered to vote in two places that's
not against the law as long as you don't
vote in two places it's very common
that somebody
lives in one place and you register and
then you move somewhere else and you
register there you're not automatically
removed from the registration at the old
place you're registered in two places i
believe tiffany trump trump's daughter
had this going on
as long as you don't vote twice it's
okay you haven't actually done anything
wrong
the next part with the mark meadows
investigation is
the register the address where he was
supposedly registered to vote or where
he was registered to vote where he
supposedly lived was not a place he had
allegedly even been to it if i recall
correctly it was a trailer of some kind
and the circumstances are all
extraordinarily bizarre now it shouldn't
come like as a complete and total shock
to us
that this is really common but also
remember that donald trump multiple
times talked about you should try voting
twice this all of this vote by mail
thing it's so complicated that maybe you
should try voting twice here's just one
time that donald trump said this mark
meadows was trump's chief of staff at
this time
sign your mailing ballot
okay you sign it right and send it in
and then you have to follow it
and if on election day or
early voting
that is not
tabulated and counted you go vote
and then if for some reason after that
it shouldn't take that long it comes in
they're not going to be able to tabulate
it because you will have voted but you
have to make sure your vote counts
because the only way they're going to
beat us
is by doing that kind of stuff so trump
said even if you submit a mail-in vote
you should still go and try to vote
again because if they don't receive
anyway but what he's saying is try to
vote twice
try to vote twice and of course it all
is predicated on the idea that the
mail-in votes are going to just end up
some some kind of netherworld some kind
of election purgatory of sorts uh but
remember
they never actually cared about voter
fraud
they never really cared about it they
care about
what are the ways in which they can
weaponize confusion
and misinformation to help themselves
win
they want to use voter fraud as an issue
to make it harder to vote and that
includes closing polling places reducing
early voting hours reducing vote by mail
doing doing all of the things that make
it harder to vote strategically only in
certain places notice that they don't
really care about this in california
they don't care about this in
massachusetts
they don't care about this in
connecticut they care about it in places
where they can think to themselves okay
let's evaluate the electorate
and evaluate policy
and if it's a state that could be close
let's see what kind of
disinformation we can push or what kind
of laws we could seek to have changed
that would maybe give us a little bit of
an edge or at least give us the
opportunity to later challenge it that's
another part of it because sometimes we
hear oh well it it's not clear that
closing polling places in michigan
would help them in the sense that you
might close polling places in michigan
and it makes it harder for democrats and
republicans to vote okay maybe
first of all typically they argue for
polling places to be closed in urban
areas that have more democratic voters
they'll say
there's too many polling places we don't
need this many polling places so that
makes it harder for democratic-leaning
areas to vote but the other part of it
is
they just want to create a pretext to
then later challenge votes
and uh making changes to where and when
and how you can vote creates a pretext
that then you can use to say things
didn't go right we're filing a lawsuit
or we're filing a complaint of some kind
um what else did we have i mean this
these are really the main things and uh
as as always
if they keep saying the left is going to
do this it probably means they're
already doing it
i think some of you are going to find
this pretty funny
one of the things that by the way
speaking of projection
one of the things the right criticizes
the left for
is this idea
that anything goes
any opinion is valid and they call it a
form of post-modernism where everyone is
supposed to get an equal seat at the
table and we have to listen to all
opinions and value them and consider
them all equally now it's not true
it's not true
but as is often the case
it is they who are doing the very thing
which they accuse others of doing we
call this projection
charlie kirk a right-wing ideologue who
speaks
overwhelmingly to college age people and
tries to convince them to become right
wingers
he is now saying
inflation
may be caused by trans people by
transgender people
uh if i've ever seen an example of this
sort of pseudo postmodern
every opinion is valid
everything is connected sort of thing
it's this
take a listen to this this this is this
is beyond words
so one of the reasons why
we take such a strong stance and opinion
on the trans issue right is it's an
issue of reality
you do not get to determine your own
reality do not get to all of a sudden
say i'm rich or i'm poor no we actually
have to look at some evidence of whether
or not you're rich or poor now some of
those are relative terms rich according
to who which according to what i
understand that
but relatively though some of the terms
we use short tall
you can't just make them up you say oh
wow that person is taller than that
person that person is faster than that
person fair and stronger than that
person so far so good and one of the
reasons why we've been so insistent
against this idea you can change your
gender
or change your sex or change both of
them
is that when you start to indulge
in the belief
that you could become whatever you want
and reality is subjective not objective
you're gonna have ramifications that
nobody anticipated or intended okay so
there is a direct connection to
inflation
and the trans issue wow i say charlie
come on they couldn't be further apart
no they're exactly the same
they're the same in this aspect
when you believe that men can become
women
why wouldn't you also believe that you
could print wealth
oh man is it that's rich isn't it
isn't that there's about seven things
that have to be unpacked there if you
believe that someone can change their
gender why wouldn't you also believe
that money is wealth
now there are very simple laws of
economics just like there's laws of
nature those laws of physics laws of
thermodynamics laws of biology we must
live we must live according to those
laws what's really funny about this
is so so so let me i'm going to
interpret what he's saying
he says
that
the ideology
that one can pick their gender
leads to
inflation in so far as
saying you can pick your gender
is like saying you can print money
without causing inflation
neither is true
but that both are sort of magical
imaginary beliefs not based in reality
if you believe one you're likely to
believe the other if you believe anyone
can pick their gender you believe you
can just increase the money supply with
no effect and you're likely to do it the
people who believe you can pick your
gender
are more likely to believe you can
increase the money supply with no effect
and the problem with this is
it's so absurd that it's hard to even
discuss it on its merits but the the
general principle that applies here is
projection because i could turn this
around
this doesn't lead to productive
discussion is the point i'm trying to
make i could turn this around and go
listen charlie you know
the idea that you cut taxes for the rich
and it helps the economy
that just that's just imaginary that's
just as imaginary as anything else and
you can just link two things you can
just link any two things
if
vaccines
are related to trickle-down economics
david what what are you talking about
yeah i mean listen if the belief that
the vaccine doesn't work
is just as imaginary as the belief that
cutting taxes for the rich
is good for the economy
oh okay i've just linked them does this
actually substantively improve our
understanding of either of those issues
vaccination or taxation no it doesn't
and similarly charlie kirk saying well
the idea that people can believe things
that aren't true can be used to link any
two issues it doesn't mean there's
actually a condition connection between
trans
and inflation what's the purpose of this
though
the purpose is to start grouping
ideas they don't like together
even if they don't actually have any
business being grouped together with the
idea of convincing people by saying well
if you believe either of these things
you have to believe the other they must
both be wrong so i should reject both
both beliefs that's the idea
it's to weaponize the anti-trans people
when it comes to the economy under biden
or the other way around to weaponize the
economy under biden to convince people
that they shouldn't be for people being
able to live in the way that aligns with
the way that they feel so it's bogus
it doesn't lead to anything productive
but this is the ben shapiro type stuff
that you go to a college campus and
people hear and they go wow charlie's
making a lot of sense there it really
makes a lot of sense it's their version
of the anything goes post-modernism that
they say exists exclusively on the left
and they're not going to stop because
this works he goes to college campuses
and he says this stuff and people just
donate they just give them money they
give money money money it's extremely
profitable it's extremely effective and
it's extraordinarily depressing
we have a voicemail number
that number is 219 to david p
here is a
voicemail which argues this is actually
very interesting
that what putin is doing
is no different than what american
settlers did
to the native americans of the united
states take a listen to this
have you got any streets much yet
no
have you figured out what the difference
is between what putin's doing
and what our forefathers did when they
came here and they just killed everybody
for the property that was here okay no
like the indigenous people
there's no [ __ ] difference
do you honestly understand
the united states there are no united
states
there's 50 different [ __ ] countries
in north america
they do whatever they want
and the government
doesn't do a goddamn thing
and we're supposed to be the united
states are you [ __ ] kidding me
are you [ __ ] naive
so the person does seem unhinged but
part of the argument that he seems to be
making is
what putin is doing in ukraine is no
more right or wrong than what our
forefathers did in the united states
well i mean listen
circumstances are different but there's
a grain of truth to that
if someone had been able to stop our
forefathers they probably would have and
so the fact that
the people who came from europe to
colonize the united states were able to
do it because they didn't meet enough
resistance
isn't a very good reason to say what
putin is doing isn't really that bad or
should be allowed to go on it i mean
maybe the guy's making a good point but
when i hear that i say oh well i mean if
the natives had been better equipped
they might have rejected
the colonial settlers from europe that's
not a reason to let putin take whatever
the hell he wants kind of an interesting
i mean a very angry person very unhinged
but making an interesting point that i
think should be considered but maybe
considered in a different way than he
wants me thinking about it interesting
stuff we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today iowa and new hampshire are not
guaranteed to be the first primaries of
2024. we'll tell you what's going on and
why we will also talk about the
extension to the federal travel mask
mandate which applies on planes and
elsewhere
and lastly
governor greg abbott of texas doing
quite a quite a stunt with a bus of
migrants going to washington dc will
tell you what's going on and what they
hope to get out of it all of those
stories and more
on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors cheese butter is
the delicious gourmet cheese melt that
blends four indulgent cheeses and
seasoned butter i love this stuff
perfect on bread bagels sandwiches
veggies and more and you'll get 20 off
when you go to cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below